les réunions chez microsoft met en place
après la pause et on s'en va comme ça
c'est pour ça voilà ça c'est très bien
chez ikea
non mais des voyelles ta gueule c'est
pas facile chez haribo c'est bon c'est
bon de ces mecs c'est bon j'ai lancé la
chaîne youtube youtube qui appartient au
fils à papa lé là je suis parti un peu
style faut patienter un peu alors allez
on y va et action action
ouais
allez on y va chez youtube
mon chéri voici le bébé voici la liste
des huit enfants
voici la liste de ce type ont passé chez
nintendo et définition du som à la ratp
je te regarde je me vois chez nrj 12 les
anges de la télé réalité à me dire voilà
à les mots d'un balai chez free le prix
tombe à 16 euros
oui je suis à temps dépassé les bons
ouais oui et oui oh oui oui et oui oui
l'école est finie c'est mon idéal et
madison
elle s'appelle madison la femme de
didier chez orange what car
oui je sais je sais j'ai vomi sur notre
table sont atteintes du salon de ma mère
chez avast la base virale b ps a été mis
en place à marcher ça veut dire c'est
pas mal hein le prénom d'annam enchanté
pas violent c'était très bien les
réunions chez snapshots quand même
dommage que toutes les photos sont
supprimés non mais c'est tout moi quoi
gbit/s que 400 euros le casque ça sent
l'arnaqué
j'ai technikart gravity les gens vont
adorer ou détester mais le dernier
coldplay
c'est un bide c'est l'album de l'année
et on peut le dire bravo à vous
puisqu'elle n'avait rien à branler alors
j'ai dit ok ce que 600 euros les
écouteurs ce sont les mêmes chez newport
dégager un peu de boulot attraper la
blue glow en fait moi parce que la
vallée non non on bat pas on va pas
arrêter ça non non non non non je casse
toi genève